yeah give us a little spin let's see
[Music]
yeah we are already famous uh just for
dressing it up like people from here
they are happy to see us like this
[Music]
how was your experience wearing it ah it
is uh it's very it's great because
everybody wants to take photo with us
I just feel a little bit like a local
it's a wonderful experience for me um I
like this head uh this headpiece a lot
like I look very Royal
I found it it's really difficult to put
on this mask I tried multiple times it's
getting always getting loose but some
lady local lady helped me like I redo
this I needed more practice
but with the dress it's very hot here
maybe I should wear less things
this is the main issue
[Music]
this is one of the main goals about the
World Cup what are we doing here we want
to bring people to see our culture so as
soon as I see someone is wearing my top
and my guitar and they keep asking if
it's good I am I'm wearing like correct
I'm saying yeah it's okay I'm happy with
it
[Applause]